wonder woman von patty jenkins das ist
ein film über das leben von der jänner
also der wirklich in die er nicht kannte
philanthropen aus großbritannien die
unter journalistischer feindeinwirkung
gegen einen pfosten gefahren wurde
sondern die echte da jener prinz
prinzessin von kempski rat auch das an
die polizei
eine amazon republik haben die götter
frauen hingestellt die den männern
erklären sollen dass immer nur krieg
auch ein spaß macht und da sind ein paar
tausend jahre und dann fällt ein pilot
aus dem ersten weltkrieg an die küste
von dieser insel wird dort auch wasser
gezogen der erste weltkrieg stolpert ihm
hinterher und dann gibt's auf die mütze
wofür zuständig ist eben die prinzessin
dieser amazon
[Musik]
bringen
er verwandelt an der wechsel von wanda
wohnung dass sie tatsächlich zu einer
anderen absicht erfunden wurde als der
damit ein auf geldgeschäfte william
augenmasken 1 erfolgs pädagoge und
humanist kann man sagen hat sie ungefähr
140 erfunden von der zeit wo in den
verein staaten von amerika durch
wirtschaftliche und militärische
geschichten ist klar war die frauen
werden andere sachen machen müssen als
kinder küche kirche und der beutel
positives vorbild
und von da an gibt es viele viele comics
über viele viele jahre und gibt auch
eine fernsehserie aus den frühen
siebziger jahren und sehr viel material
so dass in amerika diese figur absolut
auf augenhöhe ist mit superman oder
batman hier nicht so bekannt ist wird
dieser film aber wahrscheinlich ändern
wenn er ist weiß ich das noch nicht
gesagt habe sehr sehr gut
schlauerweise basieren sie den film vom
visuellen her aber auch von dem geist
der atmet her auf der besten periode der
besten zeit in der wahrnehmung
geschichte nämlich dort faires und wer
das ist jemand der sich eben über das
design ganz neue ganz tolle gedanken
gemacht hat die nach 30 jahren immer
noch frisch sind der diese ganze
griechische welt mit die mythische die
sagenwelt mit einer aktuellen gegenwart
unserer welt auf eine interessante art
verbunden hat der kreativ mit einer
grund ist neben umgegangen ist mit den
rollen seiner figuren mit der
psychologie dieser figuren
ich glaube sie sind im besitz von etwas
das general ludendorff gehört naja die
figuren mit denen es steht und fällt und
damit auch die darsteller mit denen es
steht und fällt sind einerseits tiefer
es ist männliche love interest also wir
haben hier spiegelverkehrt das was man
hat ihm einen helden film hat es gibt
irgendwie auch ne maus die der held
haben wir nur da erhält eine frau ist
ist es halt neugierig und chris pine ist
verdammt fischer mal sich also der
hatten die blauen augen und der war
schon als captain körper star trek super
und er ist hier noch super gau ich
gehöre den britischen krankenkassen
das ist dass der für sich und gott
kalkar dort was soll man sagen ich
versprechen schon sagt margot geiger
dort die frau die forderung spielt
der witz hier ist wie man das erste mal
seit den batman film von christopher
nolan das gefühl hat dass diese dies die
sachen überhaupt ins kino gehören dass
sie überhaupt nicht nur so mühsam
animierte relativ steife staatsmittel
oder anatomie von irgendwelchen
muskulösen leuten die für eine idee
stehen sind sondern dass es menschen
will ich kann ich das nicht so lustig
war so natürlich gefilmt was für fans
der punkt ist nur dass einige leute da
reingehen rauskommen werden und das dann
sind das heißt um es mal ein bisschen in
die allgemeine zu öffnen ich würde sagen
der film ist besonders für frauen für
leute die frauen werden möchten für
leute die früher mal frauen waren und
für leute die sich in irgendeiner form
für frauen interessieren sich dann doch
ein paar